if you're looking for ways to achieve
more work/life balance for real then
this video is for you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
Wang root is believed and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world now I often get asked
by entrepreneurs how do I have work/life
balance my business takes up so much of
my time I don't know how to balance
everything and make it all work together
and so today I'm gonna share with you my
seven ways on how to achieve work/life
balance for real all right so way number
one is define it for yourself work-life
balance is a really personal thing I
remember looking at the rock and his
schedule and he likes to wake up through
two four hours before he has to get on
set for making a movie so he can work
out so he loves working out for a couple
hours before he gets on set and to him
that's balance he says that's how I keep
my life in balance and to me looking at
that I think he's crazy
I can't imagine waking up three to four
hours earlier than I need to to show up
for a meeting to show up for filming day
like this just to work out for a couple
hours you know I did 25 push-ups before
coming here instead of doing my usual
half an hour on the bike because I was
crunched on time and so just that's
balanced to him but to me it sounds
crazy and that's okay the goal isn't for
you to judge somebody else's version of
balance it's for you to figure out what
balance looks like for you and so you
might look to me you might look to the
rock you might look to all these are the
people that I'm profiling and see what
they do and that's just to try on the
hat try on the vest try on try on the
jacket right like you try it on you see
does that work for you and if it doesn't
serve you then get rid of it and the
ones that do then you keep it so it
might mean you wake up super early it
might mean you have X amount of time
with your family X amount of time with
your your business that might mean
you're chunking your times a lot of
different strategies and if you don't
know what to do then you try them all
and then you pay attention does this
work for you just because it works for
the rock it doesn't mean it's gonna work
for you just because it works for me
doesn't it's gonna work for you and so
by pulling out these different pieces
it's figuring out what balance means to
you and until you define that for
yourself
none of the strategies will work
you have to know what that looks like
for you and then you can plan around it
all right wait number two is now we need
to make a realistic plan and I think in
general we tend not to make plans that
we can actually keep - and that are
realistic we try to plan for our ideal
day which is great so fantastic exercise
to think what does an ideal day look
like for me how would I love to wake up
and spend my day every day that exercise
is awesome to do but don't expect that
to happen and at least not immediately
you have to be able to make it realistic
because what ends up happening is if you
say I want to wake up but I want to I
want to work out and I want to meditate
for thirty minutes and I want to watch a
video and then read a book and my
perfect morning routine is like three
hours to get me ready maybe one day you
wake up but you don't have those three
hours maybe something crazy happened to
you at night that keeps you up late and
then you can't wake up that early in the
morning and you're sleeping in and then
you feel defeated this is a big
challenge of creating unrealistic
planning is that when you can't achieve
it then you get down on yourself and you
feel bad you lose self-confidence and so
being able to make a plan that you can
stick to a plan that you factored in
your life and how it is working right
now and you're making it to build a
better life so this is where you are now
this is where you want to get to and
your habits and your team your schedule
will guide you this way making sure that
what you can do right now is realistic
is super super super super important
we number three is involved the
important people in your life so if you
are single and have no responsibilities
and nobody else to plan your life with
and it makes it a lot easier but if
you're not if you have a team you have
to be responsible to them if you have a
husband or wife or boyfriend girlfriend
or parents who need you or kids who need
you then you are not making your plan in
a vacuum
you've got to involve them and so as an
example one of the things I did when I
was taking over trying to dance also
this business was I sat down with my
wife Nina and I said I need to figure
out a plan that works for both of us
because this business is mostly a
nighttime business this isn't a
nine-to-five kind of business people
aren't coming at three o'clock in the
afternoon to take a dance class right if
you could come I have to work to take a
dance class and so we are busy every
night of the week and then on Saturdays
and Sundays during the week and so for
me to meet with my instructors and visit
classes and give feedback and help build
the business some of that would happen
during the day and Monday is my TDS day
but a lot of that would have to happen
at night and we have parties and socials
and events we've events three times a
week we have classes every night of the
week and so my concern was spending so
much time at TDS for the evenings and
not having enough time for Nina and my
son and so we sat down and made a plan I
said okay the maximum I'm going to be
out is three nights a week the maximum
gonna be out doing TBS stuff is three
nights a week and then I was able to
plan with my assistant to say okay
Sandra the maximum I'm gonna be out of
three nights a week what I need to do is
have one at a week visiting somebody's
class one night a week going to one of
our events and parties in one night a
week mentoring and training with
somebody on my team
and then she makes it all work she's
fantastic Sandra thank you you saved my
life and so what I figured that out with
my wife this is the balance we can
handle in our relationship right now
maybe that changes maybe more time frees
up or maybe we need more time together
and then that might make an adjustment
but not making your plans in a vacuum
and involving the people around you who
also need your time and getting them
involved in a plan like getting there
buying on the plan is super important
when Nina said okay three nights a week
is something we can deal with and that's
doable that's manageable that's what I
like then I can plan around that and
we're both on board and creats for much
much more harmonious marriage in life
way number four is schedule your time if
you want to have good work-life balance
you need to set yourself up for success
so for me I found having a schedule that
I could follow on a daily basis has
really really helped me create a life
that is both productive and really
fulfilling it wasn't always the case for
me though there was a time before I had
a schedule I would just work all the
time I felt like I was always busy but I
never got anything important done and in
addition to that I wasn't taking care of
myself
and health-wise or my spiritually and I
didn't have time for my friends or
family and I felt a little bit resentful
at times I felt like I didn't have a
good work-life balance until I made the
decision that I'm going to take the
responsibility and creating a life
around what I care about and it was
really simple all I had to do was just
to create a schedule for myself so
here's what you need to do to create a
schedule for yourself think about the
three most important aspects of your
life so for example your work your
relationships and yourself and this is
also a really good time to kind of get
real and be honest with yourself really
other priorities under each category
actually priorities are they actually
that important so you want to put things
on there that are absolutely important
and a priority for you and once you have
done that and you feel good about it
it's time for you to transfer that over
to a calendar now I use Google Calendar
you could use whatever calendar that you
want as long as it's easy to use and
it's easy to access because you're going
to be needing to do that every single
day so here's a fun part you get to put
all those priorities and put it on to
your calendar and schedule it in around
your life but the important part is you
need to make sure that you actually
follow each different time slot as if it
was an appointment that you cannot
cancel and you need to stick to it every
single day and yeah of course you could
change it on a monthly basis or every
quarter but it's important to stick to
it for it to work
and I promise you if you follow this
every single day for the next 30 days
you're going to see a massive difference
both in your work and life way number
five is check the box I'm a big fan of
momentum and sometimes you're not able
to follow your schedule and your routine
exactly to the T some times you have
crazy things that come up maybe you have
this really late night party that you
have to go to or maybe you're
celebrating somebody's birthday or maybe
something falls apart in your business
that you need to handle you know not
every day is gonna be perfect and you
will have days where it's really hard to
keep your schedule I'm a big fan of
momentum and I try to at least check the
box if I'm not able to do the whole
thing so what do I mean by that
I look at today once a month I come into
TDS I have my cameraman Jason he sets it
up everything looks beautiful and this
is a once a month thing that we do and
I've got to be here early in the morning
and we filmed pretty much for the entire
day something I do once a month I try to
make quality videos for you guys when I
do that on that one day a month I'm not
able to stick to my usual morning
routine I can't as an example go and do
my workout on the bike I like to spend
my mornings 30 minutes every day on the
bike answering your questions in social
media
that's the time when I check my social
media it's a lot of fun bringing a lot
of joy I'm not willing to wake up
earlier like the rock because then I
don't have as much energy to bring to
you guys on camera but I still want to
be able to check the boxes saying that I
worked out I don't want to lose the
momentum of not working now and so I'll
find a small way to do it and so for me
it was 25 push-ups in the morning if I
can't do 30 minutes on the bike I do 25
push-ups in the morning or as many as I
can do it set it off was like 15 and 20
and I'm about 25 before I get too tired
and that takes 30 seconds to do I can
always find time to fit 25 push-ups in
but I can't necessarily always find time
to fit the 30 minutes in another quick
example is I'm trying wim Hof's
breathing method it's really helped me
this year I've gotten sick once all year
long which for me is amazing because
they used to always get sick and I
credit part of that to wim HOF and using
this breathing technique part of what
that is is doing 3 sets of 30 deep
breaths and then holding your lungs with
no air in them for as long as you can
and that takes some time to do every
morning
so if I'm really rushed like a day like
today
I'll do one set instead of doing all
three I'll do one is it as good as three
no but at least can check the boxes say
I did that exercise if you can't do it
on a consistent basis the whole thing
you're doing a little micro part of it
so you can check the box now if that's
happening every day if every day you're
only doing 25 push-ups instead of doing
the full 30 minutes on the bike or that
equivalent for you then you need to go
back to one of the previous points
around setting a realistic plan because
you don't want to fall short
consistently but just expect things to
happen in your life but there are some
days you just can't stick with it but
you still want to find some money to
check the box to keep the momentum going
way number six is reevaluate if you're
off consistently so back to my last
point if you're finding that you are not
consistently doing things that's where
it's useful to have a habit tracker or
some checklists or something that you're
doing to be able to track the habits in
the machine that you want for yourself
the track what a balanced life looks
like and so you know what things you're
not doing consistently then you have to
ask yourself is that a realistic goal is
that something that is still important
to you and if it is how do I carve out
more time in my schedule to make that
happen
either it's not an important goal for
you or it is and you just don't have the
spot on the calendar you have an etched
out time for it to happen so example if
you have date night planned and every
tuesday night is date night for you and
you're only hitting it once a month
instead of four times a month or five
times a month sometimes then what's the
problem
either date night is not important
enough to you and should be eliminated
or you're allowing other things to
encroach on your Tuesday night that date
night doesn't happen sometimes things
will get crazy and you will need to do
something else on that Tuesday night and
that has to be okay but if you're
missing Florida of every five three out
of every four that's a problem I need to
adjust your schedule so it's a constant
battle of reevaluating your schedule and
also of news flash back to point number
one what you see as work/life balance
will change over time it's not like you
have this perfect vision of work-life
balance and that's going to be set for
the rest of your life it will change it
may change from week to week it might
change in once a month quarter a quarter
year to year but I guarantee that's not
gonna say the same the person you are
now and what you see is work-life
balance
right now will not be the same in two
years and so you need to be constantly
re-evaluating am I happy um is my life
in balance so I'm working enough am i
spending the time with my family am i
spend enough time personally doing other
things I get no judgment over what that
mix is but are you happy and if not then
again going through all the steps
reevaluating your schedule and making a
plan that works for you I we number
seven is to reward your discipline
sometimes it can be really hard to build
new habits especially with something
that you want to do or you know is good
for you but there's all these
temptations not to do it so for me an
example working out being on the bike I
know that it's important I know that as
part of a healthy lifestyle I don't know
that I feel the benefit every day of
going on the bike and so I reward my
discipline by tying it to something else
that I really like so for example I use
the social media when I'm on the bike
every morning and just on the weekends
I'm responding to your social media I'm
responding to your tweets and to your
snaps into your instagrams and that's my
time that thirty minutes every morning
to be able to reply to you guys and if I
miss the bike like I did today
I don't reply in social media I'm not
getting back to you guys and it's not
the pressure of like I feel like I need
to get back to you I enjoy it so I'm I'm
missing out on this activity that I
enjoy doing because I didn't do the
habit that I'm trying to build and so by
linking some of those things together by
rewarding the discipline of doing the
habit that you want to try to maintain I
find that it really helps me and so that
can be a challenge sometimes finding
what is the thing that you really want
to do and you know what's good for you
but there's there's resistance somehow
and how do i link it with something
positive that i can do maybe at the same
time so that I get a better result and
I'm more likely to stick with that habit
so those are my seven ways on how to
achieve work-life balance for real I
made this video because Perla girl asked
me to if there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in a future video check out the
link in the description you can go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what rule was your favorite which rule
is most applicable to your situation
right now did I miss an eight nine ten
that you want to add to the list
have your say leave it down in the
comments below and I look forward to
seeing what you write I also want to
give a quick shout out to Dave Gardner
from the David Gardner com thank you so
much man for picking up a copy of
I booked your one word and doing the
review on your website and showing off
that awesome picture I really appreciate
the support man and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
values is that we believe that people
with passion can not one drop of my
self-worth depends on Europe it's
something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details